i thought instead of giving you an
overview which is probably uh you can
get from really the website of the
commission which is
hiv law
commission.org i try and make the link
between the topics uh to be discussed in
the next couple of days and the work of
the commission
and that's criminalization and
what's the commission doing in in
relation to that you'll get a lot of
information on the commission
like i said on the website
um it's it's it's it's it's real goal is
to develop actionable evidence informed
rights-based recommendations for
effective aids responses that mitigate
the impact of hiv and promote and
protect the human rights of people
living with and most vulnerable to hiv i
i mean this is a very dry boring jargon
filled statement but i think the idea is
that the commission
um
makes
these
recommendations not to lie on the
shelves but to be used by policymakers
and to be used by advocates to actually
see that actionable stuff happens on the
ground and that reform takes place
um and i could talk a lot about all
about how things already moving in
somewhat in certain directions but but
we don't have the time happy to take
questions
uh
during breaks and stuff um
so
so here so some of the objectives the
commission were to analyze existing
evidence and generate new evidence and
i'll explain to you how some of that has
happened because it relates directly to
this topic
um
develop the recommendations increase
awareness amongst key constituencies and
so there's been a whole method by which
we've tried to engage law and policy
makers at national levels with um and
civil society bring them together have a
conversation increase awareness
revive some of the conversation which
has kind of fallen by the wayside around
a lot of issues on hiv and the law
and actually encourage a public dialogue
and i just got back actually
interestingly enough two weeks ago from
a very public dialogue
on hiv and the law in belize
where the entire dialogue was broadcast
on a radio channel which is listened to
by everyone in the country to the whole
country so everyone was listening in and
the government of course got completely
stressed out and i was harassed at
immigration
but uh it was it was interesting that we
just opened up the whole conversation
around sexuality and morality and stuff
and it was a
so we're already seeing a little bit of
uh movement
um and then like i said engage with
civil society empower civil society to
actually be able to advocate for change
uh the commissioners you will get their
details again on the website
this is the these are the four focus
areas of the community
it must kind of look at laws and
practices that effectively criminalize
and discriminate against people so
that's very broad language but it
certainly includes criminalization of
transmission exposure as it does
criminalization of sexual orientation or
sodomy uh criminalization of sex work
laws and practices in mitigator
sustained violence and discrimination is
lived by women which includes
gaps in the law of vis-a-vis sexual
assault laws domestic violence laws etc
and how they impact our vulnerability
and of course women who are hiv-positive
and how discrimination reinforces their
marginalization and actually affects
their health
uh treatment access issues related to
the law particularly patent law and then
finally issues of loan hiv pertaining to
children that's a variety of things
including age of consent issues
the commission will uh which began its
work in june 2010
it will conclude a by early next year so
we have a time frame and all this has
happened pretty rapidly
uh but it's happened with a lot of
consultations so i think there's a lot
of mobilization around
uh this just taken place in the last 18
months
um
i thought this would uh i i thought i
should share with you this which is most
kind of
uh topical for this this this
this meeting we're having now what are
the outputs of vis-a-vis criminalization
of hiv transmission exposure that will
come out of this process well there are
two working papers that have been
written
uh the working papers are going to be
published but they're presently being
finalized they'll be on the website and
hopefully published in a journal of some
sort uh there is matthew wheat's paper
which is a global review of the law on
criminalization of hiv exposure and
transmission and then scott barris and
matthew have written a paper on the
criminalization morality
uh
moral responsibility for sexual
transmission
and then we have this whole process of
regional dialogues uh so we've had seven
of these across the world where we've
got civil society and government
to sit across the table and have a
conversation
on a lot of these issues and this
process
called for submissions to be made by
civil society on matters that affect
them academics
people in the field people affected
uh
legal aid providers human rights
activists etc so we received about 650
submissions across the globe 62 of which
related to criminalization of hiv
transmission exposure that's sort of the
breakup of where most a lot of them came
from
and an analysis of submissions is
underway right now actually uh which
will also be published but what i share
with you right now is a very very early
stage of that analysis
we received so out of those 62 you could
see
submissions discussed the the blue
lines are specific laws criminalizing
hiv and then the red ones talk about the
application of general criminal law to
hiv and so you get a sense of
where
people uh activists etc are feeling
possibly impact and a lot of this is of
course anecdotal it's it's very much
about an individual experience it's not
necessarily scientific
you know research
but it's about often legal aid provision
in these contexts etc
and so i thought i'd just give you a
very quick overview of
well
how
what what what these submissions are
telling us
uh in three categories or well the first
is on hiv specific laws uh and we found
mostly these were from africa and high
income countries
either an omnibus hiv legislation or in
criminal code specifically introduced on
hiv
sometimes criminalizes non-disclosure to
spouses
a lot of the concerns that were
expressed include issues of the fact
that intent is not required and a lot of
these laws significant risk is not
required
uh risk reduction and disclosure or
consent are not considered as grounds
for defense there are disproportionate
sentences vague language the failure of
the law to account for the changing
implications of an hiv diagnosis in
terms of treatment
and then
matched with a lack of real proper legal
advice to defend oneself
and a weak evidence accepted by the
court so the rigour of evidence is not
really a standard that the courts
necessarily follow and you know some of
the submissions even talked about how
prejudice is reflected in the court in
the judiciary itself on a lot of these
issues
and uh impact in africa for instance
even though there were no prosecutions
there was a sense that existence of
these laws are
uh are known to people and could
potentially deter people from testing
and there's a disproportionate impact on
women in particular culture in cultural
and traditional contexts uh impact and
stigma the mere presence the law of
fuels hiv related stigma within society
and reflected in the court cases and
court pronouncements
uh and there's association with police
successes um an unlawful arrest physical
violence refusal to grant lawful
entitlements to hiv positive people in
prisons
then there were the then there were some
submissions related to
criminalization in general criminal
codes
again mostly in high-income countries
the application offenses relating to
transmission
of infectious diseases generally those
are the general criminal codes within
which this was captured uh and then
there's the application of general
criminal offences like aggravated
assault reckless endangerment etc um
there's an inconsistent jurisprudence
that has been that has been generated
through this and there's certainly a
skewed racial impact that was felt
um and then there's the third type
type of law under which a lot of this
gets captured which is public health law
fewer submissions
such laws visit the white powers in the
state
for example to isolate people living
with hiv regardless of conduct
and uh often such laws effectively
criminalize uh because migrant workers
for for instance are forcibly tested and
incarcerated and deported as a
consequence of their hiv status
um and finally certainly some positive
examples uh there have been challenges
to laws that criminalize hiv exposure
and transmission through advocacy in the
courts or with legislators so we've seen
that for instance in europe
um
and then there are there's success
because of arguments of obsolescence and
on on enforceability
vagueness and arbitrariness of these
laws which have convinced lawmakers to
take a new uh kind of take a new
position on some of the stuff and then
prosecutorial guidelines which exist in
england and wales
so that gives you an overview of how the
commission is actually
going to be engaged in some of these
issues